Let's say there's an election
coming up and I want to figure
out if there's a meaningful
difference between the
proportion of men and the
proportion of women that are
going to vote for a candidate.
So let's look at the population
distributions here.
So we have the men, some
proportion are going to vote
for the candidate.
We'll call that P1.
So this is the proportion that
will vote for the candidate.
And the rest of the men will
not vote for the candidate.
So 1 minus P1 will not vote
for the candidate.
And then for the women,
you're going to
see something similar.
So this is the women
right over here.
And some proportion will
vote for the candidate.
We don't know if it's the same
as P1, we don't know if it's
same as the men, so
we'll call it P2.
And then the rest of
the women will not
vote for the candidate.
1 minus P2.
So the not voting are zeroes,
the ones that
are voting are ones.
And these are both Bernoulli
distributions and we know,
just because this'll be useful
later on, that the means of
this distribution are the same
as the proportion that will
vote for it.
So the mean of the men, or the
proportion of the men that
will vote, so we'll call that
mean one, is equal to P1.
I should do everything
in yellow.
So the mean of this distribution
is P1.
The variance of this
distribution, we'll call that
variance one, is just these two
proportions multiplied by
each other.
So it's P1 times 1 minus P1.
And we saw this many many videos
ago when we learned
about Bernoulli distributions.
And we're going to see
the exact same
thing with the women.
The mean of this Bernoulli
distribution
is going to be P2.
And then the variance of this
Bernoulli distribution is
going to be these two
proportions multiplied.
So P2 times 1 minus P2.
Now, what I want to do, and
I think I said this at the
beginning of the video, is I
want to figure out if there's
a meaningful difference between
the way that the men
will vote and the
women will vote.
I want to figure out, let
me write this, is this
meaningful?
So is there a meaningful
difference here?
And what we're going to do in
this video is try to come up
with a 95% confidence interval
for this parameter.
This difference of parameters
is still a parameter.
We don't know what the true
difference of these two
population parameters are.
Or these two population
proportions.
But we're going to try to come
up with a 95% confidence
interval for that difference.
And the way we do that, we go
out and we find 1,000 men
likely to vote.
And 1,000 women likely
to vote.
So let's write this down.
So we get 1,000 men.
When we survey the 1,000 men,
let's say 642 say that they
will vote for the candidate.
So they are ones.
And then the remainder, 358,
I'll just say the remainder.
So the rest are zeros.
That we do the same
thing with women.
We survey 1,000 women who
are likely to vote.
But we survey them randomly.
And let's say 591 say
that they will
vote for the candidate.
And the rest say that
they will not
vote for the candidate.
So just here based on our sample
proportions, or our
sample means, it looks like
there is a difference.
But we still have to come up
with our confidence interval.
And let's just make sure we
understand what we just did.
So we could figure out a sample
proportion over here
for the men.
Which is really just the sample
mean of this sample
right over here.
We have 642 ones, the
rest are zero.
So we have 642 in
the numerator.
We have 1,000 samples.
642 divided by 1,000 is 0.642.
So you could view this is a
sample mean or as a sample
proportion.
If you do the same thing for
the women, the sample
proportion is going
to be 0.591.
Or you could even just view this
as the sample mean of the
sample of 1,000 women.
Where the ones voting for it
are one, the rest are zero.
And just to visualize it
properly, let me draw the
sampling distribution for
the sample proportions.
We have a large sample size.
And especially because the
proportions that we're dealing
with aren't close to one or
zero, and we have a large
sample size, the sampling
distribution will be
approximately normal.
Let me write this.
So it's going to have
some mean over here.
So the mean of the sampling
distribution of the sample
proportion.
And we've seen in
multiple times.
It's going to be the same
thing as the mean of the
population.
And the mean of the population
is actually the true
population proportion.
So this is going to
be equal to P1.
This is something that we
don't to know about.
And then the variance of this,
and we've seen this several
times already, the variance of
this distribution, I have to
put a one here, we're dealing
with the men.
The variance of this
distribution by the central
limit theorem is going to
be the variance of this
distribution up here, which is
P1 times 1 minus P1 over our
sample size, over 1,000.
And we can do the exact same
thing for the women.
So this is the sampling
distribution.
This is for P2 bar, or this
sample mean over here.
Let me put a one over here.
Remember, this is
all for the men.
And then this over here
is all for the women.
Can't forget those
twos over there.
And so this distribution is
going to have some mean.
Let me draw it right
over here.
So mu sub P2 with
a bar over it.
So the mean of the sampling
distribution for this sample
proportion, for the women, which
is going to be the same
thing as the mean of the
population, which we already
saw is going to be
equal to P2.
And then the variance for this
distribution, for this
sampling and distribution over
here, is going to be this
variance over here divided
by our sample size.
So P2 times 1 minus P2.
All of that over n.
Now, our whole goal is to
get a 95% confidence
interval for that.
And so what we're going to do is
we're going to think about
the sampling distribution, not
for this, and not the sampling
distribution for this.
But we're going to think about
the sampling distribution for
the difference of this sample
proportion and this sample
proportion.
We've seen it already.
We're talking about proportions,
but it's really
the same exact ideas that we
did when we just compared
sample means generally.
So let's look at that.
Let's look at this
distribution.
And just to be clear, when we
got this sample mean here,
this sample proportion,
we just sampled it.
You could view it as taking
a sample from this
distribution over here.
When we got this sample
proportion, it was like taking
a sample from this over here.
We took 1,000 samples from this,
when we took their mean.
Where it's equivalent to taking
a sample from the
sampling distribution.
Now, this distribution over
here is going to be the
distribution of all of the
differences of the sampling
proportions, or of the
sample proportions.
So it will look like this.
It will have some mean value.
I should do this in
a different color.
I'll do it in green.
Yellow and blue make green.
So I'll call this the sampling
distribution of this
statistic, of P1 minus P2.
And so it has some
mean over here.
The sample of P1 minus the
sample mean, or the sample
proportion, of P2.
And we know, from things that
we've done in the last several
videos, that this is going to
be the exact same thing as
this mean minus this mean.
Which is the exact same
thing as P1 minus P2.
So this is going to be
equal to P1 minus P2.
And the variance of this
distribution, P1 minus P2,
just like this, is going to be
the sum of the variances of
these two distributions.
So it's going to be this thing
over here, I'll just copy and
paste it, plus this variance
over here.
There's no radical sign, because
we're not taking the
standard deviation.
We're focused on the
variance right now.
So plus this thing
right over here.
So let me copy and
let me paste it.
So that's going to
be the variance.
And if you want the standard
deviation, you can literally
just get rid of this.
You're taking the square
root of both sides.
So you take the square root of
the variance, you get the
standard deviation, that's why
I got rid of that to the
second power.
And you want to take a square
root of the right-hand side
just like that.
Now, all I did right now was
just to kind of conceptually
set things up in our brain.
What we now need to do
is actually tackle
the confidence interval.
We actually need to come up with
a 95% confidence interval
for P1 minus P2.
Or a 95% confidence interval for
this mean right over here.
And because I'm trying to make
my best effort not to make
videos too long, I'll do part
two in the next video, where
we actually solve the
confidence interval.